take the Twilight movies and mash them
up with nine and a half weeks and add a
hint of secretary and what do you get
that's right Fifty Shades of Grey
yes British author EL James is
best-selling erotic novel has been given
the big-screen treatment and the result
is well to be expected first off let's
talk about the Leeds Dakota Johnson who
you'll have seen in movies like 21 Jump
Street and the social network plays
Anastasia Steele and as a lip biting
college students who toes her sick
friend a favor by stepping in at the
last minute to interview billionaire
businessman Christian Grey for the
college newspaper Anna's pretty much
just another weak female character in
the movies though on a few occasions she
does show herself capable of taking more
control than expected this is a tough
role for an actress not least because of
the nudity but Johnson's one of the
movie's main strengths she delivers a
very natural performance as Anna
despite the fifty shades of [ __ ] script
she has to swim through to get there I
really hope this movie launches her on
to much much better things as I think
she's got a lot of talent Jamie Dornan
stars as the mega rich gray who's big on
control shall we say Dornan who was so
great as a soft-spoken serial killer in
a BBC series the fall which is actually
a little allusion to in this movie does
a good job as grey despite the fact he
seems to get the lion's share of
laughable lines as for the dialogue it
is excruciating ly bad I'm guessing
that's because the screenwriter was
hamstrung by the incredible level of
control that author EL James exercised
over the movie which is such an unusual
situation especially for someone with so
little experience
there are countless cornball lines where
you just think to yourself no one would
say that in real life at least it
provides plenty of laughs though even if
many of them are entirely unintentional
as for the story well that essentially
follows Anna's initiation by gray into
his world of BDSM that's bondage
discipline domination submission sadism
and masochism just in case you didn't
know in some ways it's hard to believe
that Fifty Shades of Grey started life
as Twilight fan fiction but all that
stuff where gray tells Anna she should
stay away from him certainly reminds me
Edward and Bella in Twilight and the
Sana's male friend he wants much more
than friendship to the plus of Fifty
Shades brings with it an array of
cliches including the young
unsophisticated woman with no money who
falls for the rich sophisticated guy who
in this case happens to be just slightly
older than her yes poor Cinderella gets
her rich Prince but not without a good
spanking first then there's a cliche of
the woman who wants a bad boy or at
least an emotionally damaged one that
they can make good but there's also a
weird creepy horror vibe going on with
grey basically stalking Anna even
turning up in her home uninvited and
unannounced it reminded me a bit of the
terrible rom-com This Means War which
thought for some unknown reason that
it'd be romantic and funny to have two
male friends who were after the same
woman turning up randomly in her home
and tracking her every movement oh and
after how were introduced to grey the
scene where he hands Anna his business
card and the camera lingers over it
maybe half expect him to launch into a
discussion its coloring and lettering
Allah American Psycho the start of the
movie all feels like it happens rather
quickly
one minute Anna and Graham meeting for
the first time in the next minute
they're all hot as hell for each other
yes it never felt like there was any
real heat between the leads and their
meet-cute but while the development of
their desire did feel rushed the film
overall felt long I think it was the
ridiculous dialogue which did make me
laugh but just got more and more tedious
as a film went on obviously there's a
lot of nudity in Fifty Shades but given
what I understand about the source
material this adaptation feels rather
tame pretty softcore in comparison it's
basically nine and a half weeks with
added male nudity director Sam
taylor-johnson was always going to be
waging an uphill battle to make even a
polyester purse nevermind a silk one out
of a sow's ear which she's obviously
tried her best especially given the
onset battles between herself and author
Yael Jo she's spoken about as for the
look of the movie cinematographer Seamus
McGarvey worked his magic yet again
you'll have seen the Garvey's work on
movies like atonement Avengers Assemble
and We Need to Talk About Kevin and in
Fifty Shades of Grey he's given us
another astonishingly world shot movie
the movies design
team David and Sandy Wasco and its
costume designer mark bridges have also
done a great job creating an engraved
world through their apartments and
clothes so to sum up Fifty Shades of
Grey is a young some movie riddled with
cliches and some absolutely awful
dialogue but Dakota Johnson's
performance and Seamus McGarvey
beautiful cinematography help it rise
above what it is Fifty Shades of Grey
gets 2 out of 5 flicks now what did you
think of Fifty Shades of Grey are you
looking forward to the inevitable sequel
and who are your favorite big-screen
couples let me know in the comments
below if you liked this video hit the
thumbs-up button and subscribe for my
weekly movie reviews and interviews
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you